- I have every reason
to be mad at the world.
But I have an excuse.
I have an excuse to be mad
at the world and everything,
'cause of this right here, but I don't.
I could give up, I'm not giving up.
I can't give up.
My mind and heart won't let me.
- [Mark] All right, Jerry.
We did a nice little talk last time,
but I'd like to do the same,
kinda cover your whole
story from start to finish.
And we'll just do a little
more comprehensive talk
than we did last time.
So, before you were shot--
What year were you shot?
What year was it?
- Ooh man, okay, let me see.
When was it?
I think I was about 42 or 43 years,
it was about 42 years, I think.
Was I 42?
- [Mark] So like 13, 14, years ago?
- Something like that, probably.
- [Mark] Yeah, so it's been a while.
- Well, yeah.
- [Mark] And what were
you doing before then?
You had a full time job?
- I was a machinist.
- [Mark] Machinist?
- I made airplane parts.
- [Mark] Airplane parts,
and you were married,
single, do you have kids?
- Single.
Kids, no.
- [Mark] No kids, okay.
And were you ever into drugs, or gangs,
or anything like that?
- No, no, definitely not,
I used to play sports.
- [Mark] You used to be an athlete?
- I was a basketball player.
Have you ever heard of the magazine
called Street & Smith's?
- [Mark] What is it?
- A magazine called Street & Smith's.
- [Mark] I don't know.
- It's a sports magazine,
like Sports Illustrated.
- [Mark] Okay.
- My teacher, not my
teacher, my counselor,
said he was in line one time,
and he sees the book was open,
and he sees Ganesha High School.
That's the school I go to.
At school, he's a counselor, my counselor.
So when he grabbed the
book, it had my name in it.
They had me, I think I was--
They had me in there as one
of the top 75 high school
basketball players in
the state of California.
- [Mark] Is that right?
- And one of the top
250 basketball players
in the United States.
- [Mark] Wow.
- Basketball's my thing,
I love basketball.
- [Mark] So you're a great athlete.
- Yeah, I started as a sophomore,
I played three years of varsity,
10th, 11th and 12th grade.
I walked in in ninth grade
and those guys didn't like me.
- [Mark] Why is that?
- I was a sophomore,
and I was starting off
and they were seniors.
- [Mark] Oh, you were--
(laughs)
- Yeah, I had problems.
- [Mark] You were good for your age.
- I was mad at the coach,
because I could've played
varsity my ninth grade year.
And he told me that it may be a problem.
And my next year, it was a problem.
Guys didn't like me
'cause I was a sophomore
and everybody else was seniors.
I was starting over
them, played more time.
- [Mark] Wow.
So when you were shot,
you were going to work?
You were coming home from work?
- Coming home from work.
- [Mark] Coming home from
work, and standing where?
- At a bus stop.
- [Mark] And what happened?
- The next thing I know,
I woke up in the hospital,
I thought I was dreaming.
The doctor told me what happened to me.
He said that he couldn't
believe I survived,
but he said the only reason I did survive,
was because it was point blank range.
He said if it wasn't point blank range,
your head would have been
rolled down the streets.
- [Mark] Wow.
- And the skin up here came off my leg.
I have impaired vision.
- [Mark] It's a skin graft?
- Yeah, a skin graft, the
skin they took from my leg,
they put up here.
And this eye got a scar behind it,
it's making my vision messed up,
that's why the glasses won't help.
- [Mark] So, you lost one eye?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And your other eye?
- Yeah, impaired vision, blind, yeah.
I had laser surgery and
everything, it did no good.
I cannot breathe, or smell out my nose.
- [Mark] Can you taste?
- Yeah, I can taste, yeah.
- [Mark] You can taste.
- I used to love to read,
but I can't read no more.
- [Mark] You can't read,
'cause your vision's-
- Yeah.
- Impaired now.
So how long were you in the hospital?
- I was there for a
while, man, yeah, yeah.
Then I left the hospital,
I had to go to Rancho Los Amigos,
you remember that?
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- Rancho Los Amigos, I was
there, off the Imperial.
A rehabilitation center.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- Rancho Cucamonga, something like that.
Off Imperial, yeah, I
was there for a while.
- [Mark] So the surgery
must have been incredible.
- They said 22 hour surgery.
I had surgery on my arm too.
They took a vein out my leg,
and put it in this arm right here.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- They took a vein out of one of my legs,
and put it in this arm right here.
- [Mark] Oh, they put a vein.
- You've seen this arm
before, haven't you?
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- You've seen my arm, haven't you?
- [Mark] I've never seen your arm.
- You haven't seen this thing?
- [Mark] You always have a sock over it.
- Let me show you.
(grunting)
I got shot here too, in my arm.
Another minute.
You see this right here?
- [Mark] Yeah, I see the scar.
- You see that?
I can't move it, that's
all I can do is this.
It swells up.
- [Mark] So what did they do to your hand?
- I got shot in the elbow.
- [Mark] Can you hold that?
(mumbling)
(grunting)
- [Mark] Want me to help you?
- It's happening, i'll get it out again.
- [Mark] Here.
(grunting)
- [Mark] Let me help you.
Why don't you take your jacket off, too?
- No, I don't want to take it off.
Look at that.
There we go, you got it.
- There we go.
- All right, you see all this here?
This is as far as I can bring my arm down,
where you at, over here.
- [Mark] Right here.
- You see my arm like this?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I can't straighten it out.
- [Mark] Oh, you can't straighten it?
- No I can't, listen to this.
As long as it's hanging down like this,
ooh, it was a pain!
I kept it in a sling, right?
And the doctor told me,
Jerry, take the pain,
do not let your hand
in the sling like that,
you'll mess it up.
And then listen what he says then.
If I had my hand in my sling,
and I hold it like this all the time,
my arm would stay like this.
That's why he was telling me,
keep it out of that
sling, just take the pain.
They wanted to break it
to straighten it out.
And they took the veins
out of one of these legs,
to put it in this arm right here.
The bone was sticking out.
- [Mark] Oh, jeez.
- That was what did this to it.
- [Mark] So, your hand
was shot, or your arm?
- No, it was the elbow.
- [Mark] The elbow was shot?
- Elbow right here.
- [Mark] Were you right-handed?
- Luckily, I was left-handed.
It was softball, more in softball, yeah.
- [Mark] You're left-handed?
- Yeah, I'm left-handed, yeah.
- [Mark] Oh, that's lucky.
- Yeah.
I used to love to read, I miss reading.
I can't play basketball no more.
- [Mark] No, you can't.
- Yeah.
I used to take the seizure pills.
- [Mark] Yeah, you told me
that you took seizure pills, medications.
- This one doctor told me,
he said, Jerry, before the head injury,
were you taking this kind of medication?
I said no.
This is just how he said it, he said,
I don't know why the fuck
they gave you this shit.
It'll start making you have them.
But not just seizures, I'd
have blackout seizures.
I'm gonna tell you this story right here.
It's a good one.
I was at Kentucky Fried
Chicken one time, right?
Last thing I remember,
I was standing in line
to buy some chicken.
Then I woke up in the hospital
with these on my chest.
I thought, what the hell's going on?
I went back to Kentucky Fried Chicken.
The security guard said,
Jerry, you started tripping!
He said, man, you were
trying to fight everybody.
He said I jumped over the counter,
and grabbed all the chicken
and threw it everywhere.
And then, I jumped back over,
I passed out and went into a seizure.
Here's another story
right here, another one.
Before I was sitting there,
I used to sit down, have
you seen me on Hill Street?
- [Mark] No.
- On Hill and First Street
is the court building there.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You know what I'm talking about?
- [Mark] Yeah, I know the court building.
- It's over there.
There was a deputy that
used to come down there,
the sheriff deputy.
We really liked each other,
and we became friends, right?
We were real good friends and everything.
Yeah, it's cool, you go ahead
and stay there, you know.
One time, everybody
said, you gotta get up.
I was laying next to
the Los Angeles Times.
Somebody took my tennis shoes, my shoes.
My head was bleeding down here,
right here, bleeding real bad.
I wondered what happened to me,
I must have had a blackout
seizure or something like that,
what happened to me?
And I wondered what happened to me, yeah.
That deputy I was telling you about,
that sheriff's deputy I
was telling you about?
(mumbles)
He came over to where I was sleeping at.
He said, Jerry, what the
fuck was wrong with you, man?
I said, What are you talking about?
He said, I seen you, blood was
running all down your face.
He said, I called an ambulance for you,
and you tried to fight them,
and you scared them to death.
You guys know what he told me?
He said, you tried to take my gun from me.
You were wrestling me over my
gun, and you slipped and fell.
That's how I got control over it.
I didn't know that.
- [Mark] This was the seizure medication?
- Yeah that it, now yeah.
I knew him, see?
He said blood, I don't
know if you can see,
there's a cut right there.
- [Mark] Yeah, I see it.
- It was wide open.
He said, when I seen you, man,
you had blood like a faucet
running down your face.
He called the ambulance, he said,
you scared them away,
you tried to fight them,
and then he said, you grabbed my gun
straight out the holster and
man, you was wrestling over it,
and then you slipped and fell,
and that's how I got control of my gun.
I don't remember any of that,
but if he didn't know me,
he could have killed me.
I said, you've got to be joking.
The doctor told me I've got
to stop taking that stuff.
The medication is doing that,
you don't remember nothing.
It was real bad, yes I'm
glad, I'm glad me know me,
'cause if not, when he
first got over there--
Are you by yourself, you
gotta be by yourself.
If you were somebody else,
and you were wrestling
me for my gun like that?
He could have shot and killed me.
I was wondering what happened,
too, I said, what happened?
I don't know how I got this scar,
and got my bleeding like that
I don't remember, you see,
you don't remember nothing.
- [Mark] Yeah, you don't remember it.
- I don't remember none of that stuff.
And then, one time, it was
because of my sight thing.
Okay, I was walking,
I told you about my eye, my
vision thing with my eye, right?
I was walking down,
let me see, this street right here.
- [Mark] Seventh?
- Yeah, I'm going to Central, went up.
There's a gas station right there,
before you get to the freeway, right?
- [Mark] Mmhmm.
- All the way that way, I'm walking.
I said, man this side of the
street's narrow over here.
I'm going down the street
to cut down this way.
I said, damn, man, these
cars driving right here
like they're crazy!
There's something wrong with them.
I said, I'm gonna cross the
street to the other side.
I go across the street, damn
there's no sidewalk over here!
So I go back, when I get back on it,
they're driving clean on the side.
Now check this out, Mark.
You know why the cars were
driving on the side like that,
and the sidewalk was narrow?
I'm not doing that, I was
walking on the damn freeway!
When I got back to the street I meant to,
I seen it, and I said,
ain't this but a bitch?
What way to find out that
I was going back and forth
across the street on the damn freeway.
I thought I was on the street.
I said no wonder the damn sidewalk was,
the sidewalk was real narrow.
I was looking, and I seen houses.
I said, why them houses way
back there from the sidewalk?
And these sidewalks were real narrow.
Now, I go on the other side of the street,
man, they ain't got no sidewalk over here!
And the cars were driving crazy,
and I'm walking on the
side, and I'm blind to it.
And so, I was walking,
right here, San Pedro right
here, that's where you exit.
I saw the signs on the freeway to exit.
I said, ain't this but a bitch!
- [Mark] You were walking on the freeway.
- I was walking on the freeway
and didn't even know it!
I was walking back and
forth across the freeway,
cars are flying by, and I was thinking,
what the hell's wrong with
them, driving crazy like that?
- [Mark] You crossed the freeway?
- Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I walk on one side,
where I said the sidewalk
was narrow, right?
I said, why is the sidewalk
so narrow like this?
And I was looking like, let
me walk on the other side.
I walk over to the other side,
damn, they ain't got no
sidewalk on this side!
Cars were going.
- [Mark] 'Cause your vision is so bad?
- Right, I walk back to the other side.
I'm walking.
you know, on the freeway where it says,
exit 70 whatever, right?
I said, ain't this but a bitch!
I see a sign says, exit San Pedro.
No wonder they were flying
down the street like that!
I was walking on the
freeway and did not know it.
It was at nighttime,
not daytime, nighttime.
I said, man, man, man, man.
Another thing, man--
- [Mark] They never caught
the guy who shot you?
- I don't know who did it.
- [Mark] You don't know who did it?
- Nuh uh.
- [Mark] You never saw it coming?
- Never seen nothing.
- [Mark] They never caught the guy?
- Last thing I remember,
I was sitting like I'm
sitting right here, and pow!
I woke up, thought I was dreaming.
I said, where the hell am I at?
What's going on?
I didn't know I was in the hospital.
They said I had a 22 hour surgery.
I mean, I was messed up.
They didn't think I was going to make it.
This one guy told me, I remember seeing.
He see me,
he said, it is you.
Yeah, who am I?
Mark, do you remember they
talked about some woman,
where a monkey pulled her face
off or something like that?
You recall that, you remember that?
- [Mark] From a chimpanzee, right?
- Yeah.
He said they've got you and that lady
in the medical mystery,
medical history, medical books,
for y'all surviving
what happened to y'all.
- [Mark] Yeah, they re-built your face.
- Yeah.
Yeah, okay, they said they got me
in a medical history book for
surviving what happened to me.
One guy told me he saw me on
a video game on the internet.
And one guy showed me the cover of a CD
with my picture on it.
Okay, so yeah.
- [Mark] So do you have feelings of anger
towards the person that shot you?
- No, not really, not really.
I can't, I'm not gonna give them that.
I heard about what happened
in the video, because I--
I still go through it.
I never forget that, yeah.
People look at me, I get rude people.
Some people call me monster.
And then you've got some
lovely people out there too,
like yourself, yourself, yeah.
I keep my faith in God, though.
With God standing with you,
nobody can stand against you.
- [Mark] Were you religious before you--
I hear you mention God a lot.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] Were you religious
before you were shot?
- Oh, definitely, yeah.
- [Mark] You were?
- My mother kept us in church.
The Bible says, there's
nothing new under the sun,
the Bible says.
Everything that's going
on right now, today,
happened before in the Bible,
in the Bible, and before.
Everything, everything, like I said,
nothing new under the sun.
See, everything that happens
right now on this earth
happened years ago.
- [Mark] Do you have family?
- [Jerry] I haven't seen
my family in a while.
It's been awhile now.
It's been a long time.
I wish I could get in touch with them.
They know where I'm at.
- [Mark] They know where you are?
- [Jerry] If they want to find me, yeah.
I only talk to my youngest brother.
(mumbles)
Where you see me at the ground
over at the flower district?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Jerry] That's where I be at.
- [Mark] Is your mom still alive?
- [Jerry] Yes, well, I
think she is, I hope so.
- [Mark] And she doesn't contact you?
- [Jerry] Uh huh, I haven't talked to her.
She don't, but my youngest brother do.
- [Mark] Did you have
contact with your mom
before the accident?
- [Jerry] Before, and after, after, yeah.
- [Mark] But not lately?
- [Jerry] Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] What's changed?
- [Jerry] I used to, I
don't know, I used to--
- [Mark] And where was your dad?
- [Jerry] My dad, somebody
told me he passed away.
Recently too.
When I was growing up as a child,
let me put it this way, Mark,
so you'll understand.
I've probably seen you more
times than I've seen my father.
- [Mark] You've seen me more times
than you've seen your father?
- Just about, yeah.
- [Mark] Oh my god.
- [Jerry] He was a construction worker.
You know those twin towers
down there on Seventh Street?
Where those twin towers at?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- He was the one who helped build them.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- Yeah, he was a construction worker.
I loved math, I guess I got that from him.
He knew all that math really well.
- [Mark] But he wasn't
really in your life?
- No, nuh uh.
- [Mark] And your childhood was good?
- Yes, yeah.
- [Mark] Nothing crazy went on?
- No, no, my mother kept us in line.
- [Mark] Your mom kept
you in line, that's great.
- [Mark] You have any friends, Jerry?
- I don't mess with anybody, no.
- [Mark] No?
- [Mark] What are your
thoughts on forgiveness?
- If you about to forgive?
Well this, in order to forgive,
you have to forget first.
That's forgiveness, forget.
If you can't forget, you can't forgive.
Wouldn't you say so, isn't that right?
What you think?
- [Mark] You forget
completely, you wash it clean?
- If you want to forgive,
you've got to forget.
You can't forgive without forgetting.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah, that's it.
- [Mark] It never happened.
- Like it never happened, yeah.
- [Mark] If you're still
hanging onto the fact
that that happened, you're
not really forgiving.
- That's right.
I don't know how I can say this.
I'm not saying it the correct way,
but this is what is says in the Bible.
I can't remember the sentence right here.
Change what you can, and
accept what you can't.
Somewhere in the Bible it says that.
- [Mark] Say it again?
This is what it says in the Bible.
I'm not saying it the correct way,
but I'm saying this is
what it says in the Bible.
It says,
change
what you can,
and...
- [Mark] Accept.
- Accept what you can't.
- [Mark] What you can't.
It says in the Bible something like that.
It says, change what you can,
and accept what you can't.
- [Mark] So Jerry, if
you could have anything
in the world, anything you
want, what would it be?
- The world to be happy.
Happiness for everybody.
No homeless.
Everybody be able to eat,
live, I mean, you have a great,
you know what I'm saying?
That would be the happiest
thing in the world.
- [Mark] Nothing for you?
- That would be for me.
- [Mark] A nicer place to live?
No, the whole world, a nicer
place for the whole world,
just not me, everybody.
We'd all be happy, living in society.
What you think?
- [Mark] Yeah, that's a beautiful,
that's the most beautiful answer
you could ever give, right?
- Yeah, it is, yeah.
- [Mark] You're an amazing guy, Jerry.
- Yeah.
What you all been doing lately?
- [Mark] Wait, what?
- I gotta get me a radio,
that what I need is a radio.
- [Mark] You need a radio?
- That's what I need, a radio.
- [Mark] Let me go get you a radio.
(mumbles)
- [Mark] That's the first time
you've ever asked for anything.
- I gotta keep up with--
- [Mark] I'm asking you
anything in the world,
and you want a radio.
- Yeah, see I can't see TV.
- [Mark] Okay, I'll get you a radio.
I'll go get you one right now.
I'm asking you if you want
something significant,
and you're just saying a radio.
So Jerry, do people ever give you,
like kids ever react to you
like they're scared of you,
or stuff like like?
- Some love me, some
hate me, some will cry,
even adults, adult people.
- [Mark] What do they
think, that you're like
deformed, or what do they think?
- A lot of them think
I was born like this.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Some will be like, you have a twin?
A twin.
They don't know.
- [Mark] Oh, I see, like they separated.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like I said, some people sit by me,
(mumbles)
laugh with me.
Those kids are something else, though.
They got a mind of their own.
(laughs)
One guy told me, hey, you
gonna be here for a while?
I said, yeah.
I said, why?
I got crystal, I've
been saving up my money.
His friend, who he brought to me,
said he was gonna bring me this crystal.
He had a crystal in a bag,
I guess a crystal that's
worth a lot of money.
(laughs)
Boy, kids are something else, boy,
man, they're so beautiful!
You've got some that are scared, they cry.
And I have people call me
names, the whole thing.
But I love life, though, man.
- [Mark] What's your view of the world?
Do you see the world as a
mean place, cruel place,
or a loving place?
- It can be a loving place.
Right, I gotta say
life is just about what you make it.
So, in a way, and again,
it can be people that's holding you back.
They don't want to see you make it.
Like I said, if you keep God in your life,
it's just a loving place.
It's a very loving place.
If you have trust in
God, it's a loving place.
Definitely.
I just want the world to be
living as one, and be happy.
If the world could live
as one, and be happy,
I mean everyone, Russia, the
whole world, living as one.
One day it might be that way.
(coins jingling)